hi Paul welcome to the show yes welcome
Paul we've been on the radio together
since opine Anthony or no no I've seen
you a million times at the cellar yeah I
know Anthony show about it once outside
a stand-up New York like a week after it
happened we were standing by that little
tree remember that's the only talk about
it yeah yeah what did what exactly is it
when the when the incident occurred
I didn't realize we had I thought we
talked about that no I think we talked
about it that night you were pissed
everybody was pissed at everybody and oh
yeah yeah yeah okay and you know it was
it was [ __ ] up a really nice thing
for a lot of people so I understand that
people were pissed and I was pissed too
cuz it [ __ ] me up too you know
yeah 16 almost [ __ ] 15 half years ago
and whatever it was man I was all I did
was I just [ __ ] wanted that I was I
was working at Madison Square Garden
theater and I wanted to promote some
dates and the next thing I know I'm in
jail and my wife's like where the [ __ ]
is crazy
well we're hoping Anthony we're on
terrestrial radio obviously Caitlin they
did a contest where people had to have
sex in public or were the work could
have sex in public they weren't forced
to sure yeah but yes they couple ended
up having sex in st. Patrick's Cathedral
and it got Opie and Anthony fired from
the radio for two and a half years but
Paul was the comedian who was with the
couple who were having sex you know that
spotter yeah there was spotters there
were six six couples right Jim and I was
a spot or Voss was a spot or there was I
don't remember who else was I know Voss
was I was and it was the third year they
were doing a show and cuz I wouldn't go
out because I had already been arrested
for the show right I had been arrested
already so I said I'm not going out
there anything in right and I actually
we could circle back to that because
that had something it all kind of
related when I was talking to the cops
at 4:00 in the morning over this right
because it was so yeah so there was six
of us six couples and it was the third
year they were doing it it was
sanctioned by the network divination yep
sponsor and Sam Adams the president Sam
Adams was there and that's right well
everybody everybody kind of did this for
a while everyone the I'm on radio but
like I'm
point in both directions right like it's
his fault it's his fault yes date that
the show got screwed including Jim
because he was an employee of the show
in my opinion because the station
[ __ ] [ __ ] them you know they like
dude like you it's it'd be one thing
first of all it's shock radio so that's
sort of an agenda of like we want to
create controversy that's what the shows
do great if they went out in the Tim and
opening and Anthony just like we're
gonna do this thing and not tell the
[ __ ] in the station then yeah you should
have been fired but they they knew about
it was a third year they were doing it
everybody should have had everybody's
back and they'd been in firing before
that psycho mark who was so very funny
on the show got fired I think because he
brought someone into the boss's office
for anal sex or something like that and
they like don't do it but he did it
anyway those great radio yeah I think
that the opposite I do I don't know I
that was before my time when psycho Marc
got fired and I think it was for that
yes so they'd already had a firing
associated with that contest and they
had the warrior bus thing that happened
to you and Lou so and then you know I
remember the day of like it was
yesterday like we were in the back we're
doing the pre-production meeting this is
what's gonna happen
they hand out like a three-page document
lists of things to do and what the point
value system is right so like if you
[ __ ] in the park it's ten ten points if
you [ __ ] in a church it's ninety points
which is the highest point and there's
also it's a two-point conversion for
anal right exactly by the way at the
time yeah how happy would the news have
been to have gotten a copy of the actual
it was in the middle of the summer too
which was the worst time for the habitus
it's dead news wine oh yeah so we're
sitting in there and like it was so
nonchalant like literally oh Anthony was
playing video games the whole time like
he didn't so if people are telling us
whatever in the the one of the managers
from the station and I remember saying
because I used to be Laurie go and I
remember you just got an arrest I go
this is like public indecency I goes
anybody ever kind of rested for this
thing I'm now it's fine it's that also
tells you about the culture that we were
living in back then I mean because
because today no company would ever say
anything
never ever ever also at that time
thought they'll never fire you know is
it what the show was doing very well the
other thing that Anthony said after the
fact which was really a good point was
it was inevitable I go would even he
goes because when you do the show like
this you have to keep topping yourself
in a way yeah like you have to so you do
this yeah and then you have you know you
put a chicken a barrel with some snakes
and she's naked and the snakes you only
have butter off her [ __ ] remember that
[ __ ] 50 gallon drum challenge yeah
it's funny that you're here if we could
bring in the the 50 gallon drought years
later we actually did that again at XM
we had a girl take it out by [ __ ]
emergency services because she had like
a roach stuck in her ear so they had to
take her out on a [ __ ] a gurney or
telling you when it's over
and the whole culture of those shows
like stirring everything is go ahead
throw a cart rock at the cop car what do
you a [ __ ] like that's kind of a
convention yeah that's how I grew up in
a way like you know how big your balls
do it right and then you know we put he
we used to put each other in the barrel
so we'd be sitting around and be me you
Patrice boss and then all of a sudden
usually Opie would be like all of a
sudden they turn it he turned it on one
of us and we'd start busting that
person's balls for like 20 so it was
just what it was right so long story
short we do the pressure meeting and
then I don't want to have to walk
through all of it but like just before
we go on the air one of so this is the
might the funniest part of this then you
know what the prize was if you won the
contest it was two days and one night in
Boston in a tour of the Sam Adams beer
fest two days and a weekend in Boston
was not the greatest prize on the
Chinese bus for $11 with surprise and my
couple were these two they were sweet
but they were these two Hicks from West
Virginia like then it didn't good and
never been to the big city before like I
am Not sure they can that means they
came in to New York to try to win this
competition at their money and their
expense yeah to try to win this
competition so they can get a weekend in
Boston and hang out with their gods
right that's what this show was so hot
including Jim
they were they were godly that's what I
mean that's what it was people will be
close to the flame people wanting to be
a part of the open answers oh I'm still
thinking to myself man this is crazy but
I really need the plugs right because it
was like Thursday or something and it's
a 600 seat room and you know whatever so
I look to my right and there's a chick
blowing her boyfriend in the side studio
before the show starts and they're
filming it for the web and then I don't
know as Sam Adams do anything with this
place that I did yeah of course
can I say well the Jim cook the
president's a man was just standing
there with a beer laughing his ass off
while a chicks blowing his boyfriend
looks like smoke and pot with your
parents like this is [ __ ] that what
could go wrong everybody's like the Wild
West
and we're gonna [ __ ] a church and
chicks blowing the gorillas
multi-million dollar companies here
everyone's on board everybody ended and
this GM of the station was there and
then it can Steven Joe yeah and then we
go yeah I had to have a meeting with him
that [ __ ] he was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yes sir of the minute because
he deserves the way he treated you and
the way he treated me anyway treated
that couple because they ran for the
hills like they were [ __ ] cockroach
so you're just a guest on the show like
what are they gonna do to you what are
they well what happened was I you know I
was part of it and then should I tell
them the details I don't know if this is
boring I'm enjoying it and I don't you
know not nobody calling and beat me up
cuz I'll start to get mad and then I'll
yell at you I don't want to [ __ ] hear
it it's not my fault they'll be knocking
on their door partly my fault is partly
everybody's fault so I'm walking down
Fifth Avenue and I see a church and oh
my god
Church 90 point was on the list is on
the list it was the I think it's a
Methodist or Baptist Church at 55th and
5th or 5th I may have it off by a block
so I try to get it I'm like now I'd even
try to get him like I'll go on the side
of the church now what happened to be at
the corner of like 55th and a cop is
standing there so he's right by the
church so I go on the side of the church
and I put him against the wall now they
wouldn't take their clothes off they
kind of like dry-hump and like she had
short short running shirts on so she
pull it to the side and that God I think
I wasn't like right in there like a
micromanaging the situation and I go I
want a hundred and eighty points and
Anthony goes why go I got a church
and I got a cop on the corner I got two
for one he goes did you go in the church
I go no he goes you have to go in the
church I go what he goes you have to go
in the church now this is where I [ __ ]
up and this was my fault and I have to
take responsibility for it I turned into
a 12 year old and said ok again because
I grew up doing a public sex contest
when 12 year old there isn't and Jim
will tell you and it's there's the Sun
Sun spoken sort of pressure of like you
just have balls and do we're be
conforming because it seems like it's
it's real but it's not real because it's
a performance and it's also you know
that there's a lot of people listening
right and also your friends we were all
good friends yeah they would bust your
balls to no ends if you [ __ ] down
you're like you're right I'm sure you
get challenged that's you can only go
that high you can't do a 960 or whatever
the crazy should not people do and by
the way I don't know how you do it I get
scared on escalators
so I should have just either said no I'm
not going in a church or I should have
lied and said I went in but I thought
about that but then I'm like with my
luck these [ __ ] jamokes would find
out I lied and then they bust my balls
all right of course so I go okay and I I
tried to get in that church it was
locked so I go down the street and I'm
like I gotta find the church and I look
up and it was like you hear and it's
[ __ ] Saint Pat's gatir jungle that'll
work my brain was right and it's open
but I'm still like I'm listen I was not
comfortable doing it but I'm like so we
go in and we go way in the back like as
far as I could go like a really discreet
area and a security guard happened to
see and he's like from another country
at a bit of an accent he screamed
nothing they were just hugging I was
just saying stuff like that and then
they threw us out and we walked away and
we Oh at the at the entrance of the
church and I really meant this when I
said it the security's like we what were
you doing back there
there's another guy I go I go nothing he
was we having sex I go no they weren't
but what if they were I go what a little
heterosexual meat potato sex in the
Catholic Church is a problem but it's
okay to [ __ ] little boys
I said that to him he didn't care for
that comment I remember that and then I
in the moment probably not yeah it isn't
it isn't you know what I mean it it is
it is at this point in my opinion and it
wasn't like I had a plan or anything it
was just like you know you know and on a
lot of levels you do these contests
because you want to get caught because
that's where the controversy comes in
you hope you don't but like no one's no
one's crying over spilled milk right
like it wasn't like I'm gonna go out to
get caught it literally happened the way
I said it I should have just said [ __ ]
it I'm not going in a church it's not
worth it or I should have lied and said
I go out and win but also there was I
remember open and I think both going go
in I remember them saying go in and I
remember Anthony said you have em BRR -
almost as they said I see Anthony was
like you gotta go in the church Paul
Andrews I'd go what he goes you gotta go
in if you want the point you gotta go in
the church it's if you play it back it's
like I'm like okay now do we have it but
I can't but I can't blame Anthony I
could have just said no right like
that's on me that's totally on me
IIIi cop to that right so we go in the
church we were and I walk away we go
down the steps and we go this is where
your voyeur bus thing comes in I found
out later I'm like two blocks away I'm
up Fifth Avenue you know I'm like back
at 55th or something like that and cop
pulls up another cop pulls up and he
puts against the wall and I'm gonna go
[ __ ] right so I think we're in
commercial break and he came back from
break and then another cop pulls up and
this guy gets out and he's got grey hair
and he's got like eight rows of ribbons
lashes in Vietnam I'm like this is
[ __ ] serious right he was like your
father
like and woody what were you doing what
were you doing and I was Joe Boeing with
the cops I'm like we didn't do anything
if you want to arrest this arrest us we
didn't do anything we didn't you know
whatever and and but that frankly was I
thought part of my job like if you're
gonna put a guy out there in a mic with
a microphone on the radio and tell two
people to go in and have sex in a church
and a cop stopped you and they kept
saying don't stay on the air Mercurio
has been stopped by cops stay on the air
stay on the right so you know I'm
reading that the show wants this they
could have dumped at any time they could
have just hit the button you just Opie
Anthony the president you know what this
is getting too
whatever and you know and so I'm
standing against the wall I guess
against the wall with our hands behind
our back and the guy from West Virginia
goes because leans over he goes I can't
get arrested
I'm on probation for what he goes
illegal prescription drugs I go well
don't say that to anybody
so they take us in and they arrest us
and book us and all this other [ __ ] and
what do we have the a holic let's get
that part of the can you fight for your
40 I mean you still have that once I
have it right when it starts when they
go to Paul in the church okay let's hear
that part cuz yeah you were right that
they did say go in I should not have
said there are the steps leading to st.
Patrick's Cathedral Anthony hey Paul
yeah a lot of Worcester is checking in
complaining that your team is not
actually doing this in these
establishments and the establishments
you mean you can't just go in front of a
place like the Carnegie Deli it has to
be done inside all right can you pause
it I remember almost Opie yelling go in
the chai remember watching right and I
was uncomfortable I I think I got they
gave me the points for Carnegie Deli but
they wanted me to go in and was walking
packed and I was like you know yeah I
was kind of pushing out and so they kept
pushing me pushing me and I that's like
again like right there I just should
have said you know I [ __ ] you guys I'm
not going in I understand totally you
know that's on me you know I can't you
know I'm a big boy I got it I got a you
know I got it make me but also the show
we were and I have to say we get I was
there
the show made its own mess yeah yeah and
the only problem I had with it all is
some people for a while didn't want to
own up to their participation in the
mess and some people wanted to pass the
buck a lot of people wanted the past is
just to me those nobody knew those two
people I was the guy on the air and and
you know so I just kept my mouth shut
for a long time and it all worked out
and we're all friends again and
everything I feel bad I think he got
[ __ ] I'm pointing at Jim because he
was on a great show and it derailed [ __ ]
for him for a while and Opie and Anthony
with great guys and close friends they
wanted me to rat them out by the way
they wanted me to rat you guys out they
couldn't like by the way now it's like I
got a rest of their for now it's like
8:00 and I'm like nobody's [ __ ]
coming for me I know what's happening
everybody's [ __ ] running for the
hills
eight nine this is a multi-billion
dollar corporation they have [ __ ]
lawyers on speed dial sure ten twelve
the only person that came down was Rick
Dale got on his bike yeah did you see if
I was okay hope you didn't try to cut
nobody Anthony nobody so now I'm getting
a little pissed and I'm starting to see
the writing on the wall now I was like
2:00 in the morning and there's
ambulances I'm like what's going on well
the guy that they arrested is not was
with me was from methadone and they took
they withheld his methadone so he went
like winning the shot and they had the
rushes I'm like and by the way when they
[ __ ] I don't know if you got fed in jail
but they gave me like a longish oh yeah
a cold hamburger and Tang like even
watered-down tang it was like give you a
full spoonful of tank we're gonna write
half a spoon of the dust and then they
pull me into a room I don't know they
pull you into a room or anything with
that for us it was a little bit less
egregious you're on a bus with girls
with her it was you know again we no one
thought of it at the time this is 2002
there was a lot of funerals held in st.
Pat's from 9/11 yeah like and again
nobody considered that we just looked at
like nobody thought about the
implications of it you were just doing a
dumb thing but the cops on that one were
probably a lot more aggressive and
angrier like well what happened was and
I'm not passing luck this is why I cuz I
said to the guy at like because I
remember saying to when I were in the
production me like that any we're gonna
restaurants and somebody said a lot of
cops love us they're never gonna like
which is true like cop I'd sure loved
you guys right
because I remember cops have come up to
me after shows ago I love you guys I
know na we listed two it in the squad
car we're not supposed to bubble anyway
he said to me I said why did you arrest
us for this it says he goes because of
the it just got too much I go what do
you mean he goes first of all it was all
over the radio
they were like six you running all over
the place you were making a mockery of
the city and then the voyeur bus thing I
go what anybody goes well the guys
really push the envelope too far with
that you can't drive around in a city
with naked women there's kids in the
street bla bla bla
he said so everybody's radars been up
since the voyeur bus there and so you
know it was like we created a trap for
ourselves as a show I guess generally
and we walked right into the trap that
we didn't know what we create they
wanted to make you the example yeah and
so he literally said we got a call from
the mayor's office and like a deputy
mayor something said well I'm hearing
this thing shut this [ __ ] thing down
anybody you find arrest them for
whatever anybody I remember uh been who
worked to the show at the time then was
smart because I remember him go don't go
don't [ __ ] with the church don't throw
it Ben was the one who was against that
he was right he was the one going don't
go in don't [ __ ] do it I remember him
going right through panicking so I get
he's a Boston guy so he's just I guess
understood they're not gonna [ __ ] around
yes let's hear a little bit more just of
that of that duck you are correct you
you were pushed into going in in the
future you must go inside these venues
let's go back to the phones and check in
with the juicy right that's good and on
top of it two-point conversion in front
of the homeless guys good for 12 points
I wrote 20 feet away
very nice we're going on to the next
when I play in a minute all right thank
you Paul let's go to Paul and the juicy
lips before we take a break his team is
representing DC today Marshall and Lynn
what's up Paul we're in st. Pat's and
you're doing the balloon not inside and
it's for charity guys coming up to us
right now I can't believe I got a
religious right stop it we got it
[Music]
never know what's coming next
no but the point is can you pause it for
a second but the point is like this is
where everybody's culpable this moment
they're there giggling they're saying
you got to go in there giggling they got
like holy wait did the security enough
is enough his security Trish dump dump
get rid of him dump
don't take his call when he calls back
so that's where you know people gotta
own that you know and and I had plenty
of chances to like not do it and you
know that was on me you know and so so
then you know I'm in [ __ ] jail all
night and I'm ripped to [ __ ] now because
I had to go to my arraignment alone and
I'm like this is [ __ ] [ __ ] like
if I showed up at the thing and I just
did this to you guys that I deserve it
but you don't I could I knew what was
happening so I wanted to get in Stephens
office and I said I had to call man to
call my wife she goes where have you
been I go I mean I got arrested she goes
what what's going on I go why she goes
there's all sorts of news trucks here at
our apartment they put my name and my
address out and they would knocking on
her doors like CNN was there it goes
like WABC I said all right I'll call you
back so I went up to see Ken Stevens and
I go look you got a problem because what
I go you gotta get me a lawyer and you
get those two people a lawyer he goes
well you know
I go no no you understand you have a big
problem those what I go a lot of press
wants to talk to me right now like
literally like right now and there is
video of a chick blowed her boyfriend
with Sam Adams a guy from Sam Adams
standing in the back holding a beer
laughing his ass off and that is the
first thing I will tell the press and
you tell me how that's gonna play with
the shareholders so he get me a [ __ ]
lawyer
you were right to say that you're right
yeah well I have no percent right
because I hadn't no I had no other card
to play see I knew those attorneys from
city from like CBS and you are a hundred
percent right specials you've been
abandoned yeah I was a lawyer worked at
a big law firm don't insult my
intelligence you're not in [ __ ]
[ __ ] West Virginia where there's one
country lawyer who does wills there is
literally they have the biggest and I
can name the law firms and probably name
half the lawyers in those law firms that
work for CBS you make a phone call I
should have been on a jail within within
an hour and a half absolutely in that
couple worse off you know different
literally like there's two bump [ __ ]
and just coming up to have a good time
another poor that girl was crying and
they left these people in jail all
[ __ ] night so then I said that to him
he goes well I go look you better make a
phone call I said I need to know in two
hours I said in two hours if I don't
have a lawyer calling me I'm gonna start
talking to the press and I'll [ __ ]
blow everybody up I said cuz my career
somehow will continue without this sure
and without the show I said I don't want
to [ __ ] my friends over but if you think
I'm gonna go through this because if I
didn't do that then it was gonna be like
this this drip drip drip of like them
jerk of me I'll we'll try they wouldn't
kill ya they weren't noticing so then
they get me a lawyer and the guy who
sucked the bag of dicks because he was
their lawyer and he wouldn't do any work
he wouldn't do any proper due diligence
he wouldn't get the air check he
wouldn't do anything so I went to him
again and I said I'm getting I knew you
need to get rid of lawyer and I'm having
my own lawyer and he's gonna bill you
why because the guy's not really
representing me and I will still tell
them that this video exists and I will
tell them that this was sanctioned just
by you personally and everything else so
they let me use my own lawyer and you
know then I ended up you know getting
community service and I busted my ass
you know not I did not want to talk
about it ever be
I do not want to be one of these guys
that tried to up his career on the back
of their friends his friends
demise right like I could a lot of
people wanted to the New York potay
would chase me I'd have to go down for
hearings and they would chase me around
the courthouse to get pictures of me and
I would hide and I like I remember one
day was cold and I turned my coat inside
out so they didn't recognize me going in
and then I turned it back and out
because I didn't even want my picture in
the post because I didn't want anybody
especially the comics saying oh
mercurial is like selling out ona and
Jimmy to [ __ ] get 5 minutes of fame
and then he's gonna say I would never
talk about it I didn't talk about it for
years yeah I wouldn't talk about it
because that's just it wasn't that's not
what you do with your friends the
company did really behaved despicably by
not getting you or those guys lawyers
they really should have reacted they
wanted to distance themselves from it
and that was why they they never fired
Opie and Anthony they canceled the show
which meant that ona got paid you call
payer play they had to sit for 26 months
but they got paid the whole time I was
not under contract physically for that
like I wound up getting paid for six
months they paid me and they didn't have
to pay me so they actually did okay by
me yeah and they let me go on other
infinity radio stations to promote like
they could have been total Cox and said
stay off but they're like well if you
don't talk about this you can go on and
promote your stand-up like they they
were okay to me but I'll never forget at
that moment I was walking with open hand
towards Opie's place he lived on the
Upper West and we were walking by
Starbucks you know he's on the phone
with Bobby pand tell me they canceled
the show it was [ __ ] awful did you
did you see that coming any kind of
punishment no I I didn't know what was
gonna happen after a few days you start
to think something Bad's gonna happen
but it was the three of us walking and
he just goes alright they're uh they're
canceling the show he was relaying Bob's
message to Anton me and then we went to
Opie's place and sat on his head like a
little backyard area i think his
girlfriend was there at the time and i'm
just like my life is over
i just i I just [ __ ] I was five
months into a two-year lease on a $2,400
a month apart but I used to pay 300 a
month I was like oh my god when you were
you were pissed you were upset and I
understood
alright look I was upset I had to do 60
hours of community service I [ __ ] I
lost gigs some radio stations wouldn't
have me on my wife and I go to a church
she goes how am I gonna go what were you
doing how am I gonna go to church so
here's what happens I'm like I gotta get
was like I August there by the way
August 2013 that had 15 every August 15
for like five years at like a [ __ ]
anniversary present I get shitty emails
from douchebag fans blaming me [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you know I punched a
guy in the face at Caroline's was it
flea or flick who's that [ __ ] one
named laman or flea of something I there
was a guy who's a fan of many years yeah
I don't ever having to take a kid and
I'd done the early show then there was
another show after me so my show was
letting out there's a you know how
Caroline's a bunch of people around the
barn it's pretty packed and I'm leaving
and I go up the stairs and for people
listening you go up a set of stairs but
you can overlook the whole downstairs
bar area and a guy yells up to me hey
Mercurio you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] I go
what he goes you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
who are you goes this is now like 30
feet apart I'm up now suddenly the whole
place is quiet and how far removed is
this from the lake how long must have
been I don't know maybe like a year oh
no wait it was more than that because
you guys are back on the air because
2004-5 sorry because I know or you know
like apologize for this guy and told on
the air and told me personally that they
didn't send this guy out it was Olly so
this guy it's just these one of these
nutjob fans that [ __ ] like just can't
see the emperor has no clothes right
like you guys have this show you could
go murder [ __ ] somebody if I'm if
pees with your arm with you they're
gonna blame us and not you because the
emperor has no clothes you're the stars
they love you you can't do anything
wrong so I'm not sure if you've checked
our Twitter feature right like it was it
was a lot of like you know me and they
said [ __ ] about the couple like what are
you [ __ ] crazy anyway long story
short this guy's like calling me out in
front of everybody so I walk downstairs
he goes you you [ __ ] ruin though with
you
you ruined owene you're the review room
and I and I walked up to him and I was
so like like did I go I go you're
serious right you're not serious right I
said like because I thought it was so
great it goes yeah I go you see I
you see cuz yeah you [ __ ] he's like
really loud now if I go tell me you're
joking
I said what a third time he goes uh I go
you're serious he goes yeah I go okay so
I grabbed him by like the shirt and I
pulled him down toward me and I started
punching him in the face little bar and
I go okay I go [ __ ]
go [ __ ] yourself yet no matter what I
said I went off and then they pulled
they threw him out cuz the club I work
at the club they threw him out and I was
really pissed and I I didn't think the
show did it I cuz we were kind of okay
at that point and Opie was cool he like
went on the air and said this guy
shouldn't have done that he called me
and whatever so there was [ __ ] like that
everyone smile but then I like it got
okay but the thing that happened like
two days after was like a Wednesday or
something and I'm like I gotta get out
of town so these people that we church
with they invite us up to their house
and like Woodstock right like great
we'll go to Woodstock right get out of
the city because it's everywhere it's on
the front page of the poet because there
was nothing else that I was huge so
we're up like a nice beautiful birds a
trip when we get up so the guy the host
goes into town he gets like muffins and
bagels and coffee comes back and we're
reading the paper and I forget the paper
and I opened the first page of the post
in the [ __ ] hold two pages it's like
oh and a scandal into my picture and a
[ __ ] article and I'm like I can't let
these people see this so I take the
paper and I go into the bathroom and I
start ripping pages out of the paper and
I roll it up when I flush it down the
toilet so now I get it's like did I
clogged the toilet do I tell my clogged
the toilet because I threw pieces of
paper in it because I took a huge [ __ ] I
opted for the huge hit it was just like
people didn't talk to me like like well
you know Allah it was fall out you know
it was like a lot of shitty stuff
happened then you know you guys I but I
thought were station [ __ ] you guys
because look it was Bill O'Donoghue the
head of the Catholic League was the one
that really was Bill Donohue yeah Bill
Donohue and he was sort of just like
this you know and it's the Catholic
League and I'm Catholic you know and
this is it this is an institution like
six months earlier where the bishops had
a meeting in Rome over the pedophilia
issue and decided there wasn't a problem
so like yeah when I kind of said that
when I said that in the church I [ __ ]
men
and say what you will and Jimmy talks
you know and has points of view in his
act there was sort of comedy with a
point of view in that moment believe it
or not it was shocked radio with a point
of view I really [ __ ] meant it you're
the last people who should be judging
people about [ __ ] sex right now after
you just went to Rome with a with all
your bishops and Cardinals and decided
there was no [ __ ] problem anywhere in
the world yeah it was definitely an
understandable I mean in hindsight again
at the time you know I can only see it
like I lost like you know you you know
it you work and like I'm like [ __ ]
the business is not gonna love me and
you were no and you were breaking and
you were kind of whatever and I
understood it and that's why it would've
ended eventually though by the way that
show never right would have continued
about three friends for a while and I
knew my gut was the over time you would
you gonna get more stuff and then you'd
see it more clearly in the light of day
and like it you you did we'd get beyond
and I did so I never pressed it after
that conversation outside stand up New
York for which we talked for like 10
minutes and you were kind of pissed
you're like you know you could have done
this you could have done that and I was
like Jim you know you were in the room
you know we went we didn't yell but we
you know it was a gentleman's
disagreement and I just let you go on
your way and you let me go on my way and
we never talked about it again and we
were always nice to each other and then
over time we warned back up to each
other because I felt like I [ __ ] know
until the day I died
what I just said today that's it I
[ __ ] up I was part of it but I was
part of it
I wasn't it absolutely and the whole
show was a part of it oh and they were
[ __ ] ken Stevens was you know and
again I say been been warned everybody
and he was the voice of reason in that
moment going don't go in and you know so
it wasn't like nobody you know this is
another where other comics mad at you
because like you know ona was a big show
to promote gigs and stuff on and that
shows now gone no but you know got mad
at me was a comic I'll just say it Mitch
Patel came up to me at the strip one
night not about that remember the
Kathleen Turner thing yes he got mad at
me about that
what was the Kathleen Turner wait you
know how do we have audio that Paul
Mercurio Kathleen it was funny
very funny uh Kathleen Turner you were
in Cleveland at the time and I think you
told people on stage that it happened I
think I did too I vaguely remember that
you they said you you did you tell me
there's running video that no I don't
think there is it was just a audio I've
no no I mean audio like audio yeah put
let play up
what can we get to that part probably
gonna lose gigs again because yeah you
know the audience I I could and I could
tell it do the muscles particle let's go
to power but why don't spar three yeah
you go port one will go with though yeah
we'll go with part one no you see this
is the one I clicked this isn't say part
three there okay that's part three so
I'll just explain Kathleen Turner was
doing a play I don't remember what was
it the graduate on Broadway right and
she was nude there's the scene where she
seduces him you know just like in the
movie she takes her clothes I think was
Jason Silverman the kid from America
vaguely remember he doesn't often and I
go in with Rick Delgado
so all in Rick was recording and Rick
well what Rick yeah well I don't know
why we had to do this but we went into
the men's room and he went in one stall
and I went in another and he handed me
the recorder under the thing I don't
know why I do that but we really did
that and then Oh cuz I had to have it on
because I was saying it so we get seated
and you know it's dark in the place
going on and then let's find it yeah
even the people down there on Broadway
so and I went on the air and said well
you know jumpin
yeah remain nameless had for recording
device that's the rumor yeah yeah and
and we got three that worked no one no
one near each other
no one acknowledges keyboard this
morning even more nervous and you know
unfortunately he called me before the
show and I I'm we decided not to answer
any phone you should change moving yet
brought it down
I started person will come forward
eventually I actually think it's back
fry I think maybe someone a lot of
Travis can find it or somebody just
somebody can find that moment we do have
it is in there well why don't you
explain the moment yeah yeah yeah so we
get see didn't read the play starts the
lights go down and play starts and I'm
sitting next to Rick and then I'm
waiting for the moment in the scene
where she drops her dress and she does
and as it's coming you know that scene
and Godfather were Michael's at the
table with slot so and the cop sure and
he goes gets the gun and he's sitting
down and you hear the subway and the
cameras coming in and you hear like
almost his heart beating and it's coming
so that's exactly how I felt I'm like
and then I just like stood up as soon as
she dropped her thing and I just
screamed as loud as I could Kathleen put
your goddamn clothes back on and I
immediately sit down and everybody's
like and I mean as loud as I could and
Rick is like grabbing his mouth he's
trying not to laugh so he's like
grabbing his face right so I just sit
there
so now security comes over and they know
something happened but they don't know
who did it because I'm not tipping my
hand right so I just that was it and
then the whoever else was next to you
didn't like rat you out that's what
happened oh it's when we like that right
so now I'm like caught and I don't know
what to say so I just start going this
is disgusting I'm a Christian no one
told me there was gonna be nudity in
this play do we have this travitt I
think we have it
theft hazard none of that one second I'm
sending it tapped is a god we might have
we might have turned turn the recorder
off after that but I just I remember I
do remember I decided I had to turn the
tables on the guy and take the offense
it was smart it was smart like what am I
gonna do here
[Laughter]
okay I think we have it I don't think
anybody could get away with I'm sweating
alright that was it did you hear the gas
it was this fast I was like I'm not
kidding you it was just like that's seen
the Godfather I'm like and I just was
like [ __ ] it and I went Kathleen put
your God they have clothes back on and I
just sat like you know how when he
shoots him he doesn't run out he just
Nancy he drops the gun and walks yeah I
know I just sat down I didn't because I
don't want to draw what the gasp and
then somebody immediately Romeo and
there's another recording of that I
think there's a couple of different
remember you going I want my money back
yeah yeah so so what I did was like so
now he's taking me out we're sort of if
you're facing the stage we're pretty
much stage left in the orchestra about
halfway up I'm about three four seats in
so he pulls me out and I'm like I'm so I
immediately start like this is
ridiculous I'm offended you know I'm a
Christian I go to church
you should have told me no one there
should be some disclaimer on the unbe
comes the whole time were walk sir just
be quick so I got him back on his heels
and then he takes me over to now this
security guy there and there's a cop
there so I go I go I want I go I walk
over right to the ticket booth I go I
want my money back think about I go I
want my money back I paid good money for
these six I didn't pay for the [ __ ] I
go you people have nudity in a play and
you should be telling people if I
brought my son here and I just ranting
and ranting and raving and getting more
agitated and the guy okay sir okay
and he he pays me back the money I
usually brag about myself when I was
pretty proud of that moment it was funny
yeah cuz if you wrote the sketch it was
a perfect topper to the whole sketch so
it's funny and then and so again that
was like before warrior bus I think but
it was
I remember it was part of that whole
like we were like it was leaving the
studio and going into the world and
doing the [ __ ] that we were doing in the
studio in the world on a regular basis
and getting away with it and people
encouraging you the fans thought I was
really great because I did it the you
know the show thought it was really cool
so I was on stage I think and I did say
it and Cleveland's very a very vague
memory that was 2001 or - I think yes
somebody told me that you told the
audience that Paul Mercurio just told
terrible I probably did maybe I wasn't I
don't remember I just don't remember it
all it's kind of a [ __ ] foggy and now
I remember why they we had more than one
recorder just to be safe sure I think so
I think Rick had went on him and maybe
somebody else was sitting and now and I
never mentions Rick like I don't wanna
yeah whatever like we had a we had we
had a meeting point plan afterwards like
at a bar which we did in the met and and
he was a good producer he was it was
good and he was he was a good guy like
he he like as a producer but also just
as a person I think he like you know he
cared about like what everybody was
doing and if people you know got in
trouble and [ __ ] like that he was pretty
good throughout you know and then we
just you know kind of that was that and
then but Sony L sees me and he didn't
did Rick stay for the whole show
did Rick he goes to me and then it mitch
is a good friend so for Mitch here's a
time that I don't care whatever but he
would you know I get he goes you know I
don't know how you could do that you're
a fellow performer and how you could do
that to another performer and I'm like
you know I kind of get it yeah you know
but still but you know again he's again
like there's a hacker like yeah it's
more mature than I was at the time you
know so no not me just doing nothing
having threesomes all over just doing is
dropping Louis wins the guy blows loads
all over the place he's married he's in
Denver with eight stripper wives there's
a hot wife and they have threesomes with
girls that's a great life
find our next one yeah I never had one
no have you know I've had a couple
they're overrated yeah yeah over it and
I is I feel like you just I feel spread
thin like trying to satisfy this one and
then you get you doing something you
might never I think I'm supposed to be
loving this more than I am it's okay
like you know I don't follow me that was
nice you like that boy at the same time
yeah when I was deeply kissing one while
the other one but that was kind of fun I
would like to I would like to do one
from behind while she's eating out the
other one that would get me going I
might have done it I remember there's
those are so much hype around it yeah
this is the thing that I never yet
experiencing now I'm experiencing and
it's like oh it's just a thing exactly
you know all right so now it's just me
and it's not that special when like a
hotdog does it you know what I mean
that's right it's really not that tough